is baking sexy it seems like it's pretty  sexy right yeah it's like kneading and  making things right making things hot  massaging and getting butter all over  wow Maya you got a whole vibe going on  here of course baby gotta get the mood  right if I'm gonna be baking something  okay what's the plan step one gotta turn  my other on if my oven's not turned on  then we're doing it wrong all right  preheating I understand set that oven  right in Fahrenheit  we're talking about baking it right like  Joe needing oh yeah  be heated whisk it let's just kiss it  Maya  [Music]  we've lost her she's gone if we're gonna  be making anything tonight  if we're gonna be making anything  tonight  set the degree to get to me this is that  baby bacon music  [Music]  oh it's getting hot in here  [Music]  you okay Maya where am I was I sleep  singing Amy she got too funky so hot in  here  [Laughter]  okay